visiblement sur tik tok la cravate ça
cartonne parce que ça permet je cite de
se démarquer c'est ce que confirme jean
la trentaine j'apprécie ce qu'elle
représente le sérieux l'élégance
l'importance que l'on donne à ce que
l'on fait lorsqu'on la porte quand on
met quand on met une cravate sans y être
obligé on exprime un message je suis
content d'être là j'aime mon boulot j'ai
envie de donner mon maximum prendre les
habits de son père oui mais ces conseils
de style ça c'est moins sûr
message personnel on demande avant
d'emprunter voilà les journalistes de
presse écrite sont quand même la
profession la plus mal habillée de la
terre déjà fouette les journalistes télé
et la radio vous le voyez pas mais à
moitié ce sont les journal et les gens
les plus mal habillés de la terre dire
que derrière vous si vous regardez
nicolas par exemple derrière sa chemise
et sa cravate il un jean moche débat
c'est
un peu d'élégance au quotidien sauf si
c'est un discret mais enfin j'ai cru
comprendre que il y eut une épouse il
n'y a plus d pouze et d une nouvelle
épouse qui est l'ancienne épouse oui
voilà tout à fait
très vite revenu sur son prog les choix
puisqu'il a divorcé pour se remettre
avec sa première épouse tout à fait
ça n'a pas suffi
laurence est célibataire et laurence
l'amour est dans le slam allez-y passer
votre annonce laurence qu'est ce que
vous cherchez pas un vieux plein de sous
et patient d'accord moi c'est bien au
moins ça ça ça devrait pouvoir se
trouver ça je pense que c'est possible
alors messieurs qui nous regardent et si
vous êtes vieux riches et pas chiant
écrivait la cour et dans le slam slaves
les missions officielles un médecin m'a
dit si vous buvez un verre de plus vous
allez mourir un thème
c'est bien la preuve que les médecins
raconte n'importe quoi
rien n'est pas le seul à être récusée
par les interviews présidence
présidentielle matinale marc fauvelle
également ça veut dire que par exemple
vous interdirait également la
tauromachie
aux mille neuf c'est à dire aux taureaux
mineurs
les
candidats alors très décor il a alors
désolé monsieur l'euro oui bah oui
j'avais 16 ans vous ne pouvez pas fait
aussi bien mais ce n'est pas une lumière
sont intelligents
jamais trop loin je vais trop loin tu
déconnes il faut baisser les armes non
parce que tu peux le cas c'est peut-être
le pied gauche je suis grand talent a
dit
ça on tient des sacs à coire c'est
rock'n'roll 1
[Musique]
ces images peuvent choquer
madame
je vous explique
tout simplement évanouie 1,104 milliard
elle tombe sur les rails alors que le
train arrive mais miracle elle s'en sort
indemne les policiers l'ont sorti là et
une ambulance l'emmener à l'hôpital de
laver un titre de transport
une vidéo virale ça ne tient parfois pas
à grand-chose
à une tique tokens qui perlent équilibre
se cogne sur son lit en émettant un son
plutôt une note
et le succès est assuré par les quelque
vingt mille vidéos de ce type publié en
seulement quatre jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que ce sera le jour il partira
et dont qui choisissent la création d'un
ancien nazi qui a écrit des fleurs pour
hitler fait donc le comité médical sur
l'ascension du furet regain probable et
ça marche voilà donc ça ça arrive à au
bout d'une heure trente de spectacle
mais merci d'avoir déjà donné le la fin
et le spectacle se termine jeudi le dit
serait le spectacle mais je connais le
fil devant la mairie un applaudissement
d'accord c'est fait